une jeune femme qui a vécu c
♪ ♪ ♪
- Si les élèves se sentent
en sécurité à l'intérieur
des écoles, la réalité peut
changer rapidement une fois
- Ces cinq adolescentes âgées
de 15 ans affirment que
des proxénètes rôdent près
de leur établissement scolaire.
Leurs cibles sont plus jeunesdec
ils attaquent plus
les secondaires 2-chent des gens
vulnérables puis ils
les abordent par rapport à
genre... si tu as besoin
familiaux, "Je peux t'aider,
je peux te ramener
si t'as besoin d'habiter."
NADIA CARON, Directrice école
- Ce n'est pas une surprise,
parce que le proxénistisme,
en fait, existe malheureusement
depuis plusieurs années.
l'intervention, qu'on collabore
avec les différents partenaires.
GHYSLAIN VALLIÈRES,
Porte parole SPAL
- Est-ce qu'il y au recrutement
qui se fait? C'est partoutà tra.
Nous, on ne s'est pas mis
la tete dans la sable. On a
Ce qu'on voit c'est que les gens
savent des choses,ois
ne nous appellent pas.
- À l'échelle de la province,
le nombrloitation loitation loia
cessé d'augmenter depuis 2015.
de 764 à 2209 en 2020.
Le tiers des victimes avaient
moins de 18 ans.
Jinan, qui vient tout juste
19 ans fait tristement
partie de ces sombres
statistiques.
- J'étais 1000$ née.
- Peu importe le nombre
de clients que tu faisais?- Pui?
- Oui.
- Puis, combien de clients
tu pouvais faire par jour?
- Je pou
- Ce n'est près des écolesque s,
mais sur Internet par une banale
demande d'amitié virtuelle.ns.n.
sur Facebook, dans ce temps-là,
je me cherchais fait que
je rajoutais tout le monde.
Ça tombé que moi j'aimais
- Une fausse histoire d'amour.
Puis, un voyage à Toronto,
- "Si tu veux être la femme de
ma vie,  qu'on ait qu'on ait qut
des enfants qu'on se marie,
viens avec moi." Puis, je suis
vais être honnête aujourd'hui,
je suis allée, j'e
des clients. Puis, j'ai pas
honte de le dire, j'ai mal de
te, elle devait recruter
des jeunes filles.
- Je pouvais me faire 2000 $
par 3000 $ facile.
- Par?lle.
- Qu'est-ce que tu leur disais
pour les recruter?
- On les achetait.er. Tu sais,
quand tu sais pas ce que tu veue
ça. La fille elle va y aller,st
l'homme de ma vie, puis je vais,
elle va juste tomber dans
la geule du loup.ans plus tard,
son constat est alarmant.
Tu en vois beaucoup des jeunes
sur les réseaux sociaux,
des mineui.ui.ui.ui.ui.ui.ui.ui.
- Qui font des clients?
- Oui, j'en ai beaucoup.
- Puis, quand on parle
de quel âge qui t'écrivent?
- Ici à Longueuil, ou
à Montréal? Ou ailleurs?
- Il y en a beaucoup, il y en
a plein, c'est partout!♪ ♪ ♪ ♪ ♪
- Comme n âge, les
réseaux sociaux ont toujoursfai.
- Ma mère n'a jamais voulu que
j'aille uand tu asuand tu asuane
cadeau tu te caches, un moment
donné tu te fais un facebook
en cachette.
♪ ♪
- Le fameux application Tik Toks
créer
une personnalité, ça va ser, çat
pas habillées, sont toutes
en petites culottes, avec des
MARCO BRETON, Commandant, lutte
uelle, SPVM
- On est tous au courant des
comptes que nos enfants se
mais il y a un autre compte
- Depuis la fin des mesures
sanitaires, le SPVM remarque
reliés à des activités
de proxé
- La porte d'entrée pour
le proxénète qui veut recruter
par les réseaux sociaux, parce
qu'en 2, 3 cliques
un auditoire, une clientèle
cible bien plus grande.
- L'équipe de Maya Alieh,
qui s'occupe des cyberenquêtes,q
derniers mois; passant de ci
à 12 personnes.
MAYA ALIEH, sergen
- L'enfant de 14 ans, elle vacès
étrangers, toutes les écoles
autour d'elle, touususususususus
les gens qui mettent le mêmequ's
applications mobiles.
Alors est-ce que c'est facil
Excessivement facile.
si elle a
beaucoup d'enquêtes impliquant
des mineurs avec un faux
- Il n'y a que ça, c'est la
- Il y a des plateformes que
les contenus sont vraiment
ephémères: c'est là, çaà, ça
disparait. C'est ceux-là que
les parents devraient apprendre
jamais à l'abri de ce type
de crime
longtemps, qu'il n'y aura pas
une meilleure communication
enfants. Je pense que c'est là
qu'est le nerf de
- Elles sont encore là, elles
sont encore dans une double vie.
elles.elles.elles.elles.elles.e.
- Tu ne peux pas être heureuse,
t'es traumatisée
c'est depuis 2022 que j'aile fae
secondaire il y a  Elle particir
de sensibilisation concernant
l'exploitation sex
- Ça m'est arrivé souvent de
vouloir retourner dans cettePatt
non je ne peux pasl a vraiment t
une différence dans ta vie?
- Oui, oui, il m'a sauvée.
- Ce Pat
un ancien membre d'un gangde ru.
PATRICK CAYA, ex-membre dun gang
de rue, intervenant
en voulant être "pimp", c'est
responsabilités, on veut
se sentir important.
puis tout le monde a des rêves.
Fait que et et et et et et et et
je découvre c'est quoi ton rêve,
bien j'essaie de faire grossir
course, qui va faire grossir
le rêve
♪ ♪ ♪
- Fragile, encore vulnérable,
dans sa détermination à s'en
sortir.
- J'ai le coeur gros, je le fais
aussi, parce que moi ma mère
elle ne l'a jamais su. Elle su .
que ça va me
libérer.
♪ ♪